notre vie est politique ce matin c'est
Stanislas Guerini bonjour Merci d'être
la ministre de la transformation et de
la fonction publique on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview
avec la presse régionale
ils ont trop relevé le siège en
fait et le Sénat a donc voté 7000
articles 7 qui reporte l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans vous êtes soulagé
en tout cas satisfait que ça avance je
vais vous dire ça te fait une chose
c'est qu'on puisse parler du fond du
texte moi je suis un ministre de la
Fonction publique qui était très frustré
à l'Assemblée nationale on n'avait pas
prononcé une fois le mode fonctionnaire
la réalité c'est que ça n'avait pas
intéressé le détail la vraie vie au fond
des salariés des agents publics des
carrières des différentes mesures qu'on
peut porter certes pour travailler plus
longtemps mais aussi pour adapter le
temps de travail les postes la
possibilité de changer de métier toutes
ces sujets là on a pu les discuter avec
les sénateurs on a pu avancer et on a
effectivement
c'est pour vous c'était important que au
Sénat il y a une forme de fin de
meilleure réflexion sur le sur les sur
les thématiques des retraites c'est
l'Assemblée nationale c'est évident le
débat avait été formidable gâchis à
l'Assemblée nationale une sur idéologie
de ce débat qui est très important
qui doit nous permettre de parler de la
vraie vie des agents de la fonction
publique ils ont plus de chance pour
débattre vous avez remarqué oui ils
l'ont pris c'est une décision politique
de le faire mais moi je vois parfois un
décalage incroyable pardon mais entre
les grands discours qu'on a sur les
plateaux de télévision
très idéologiques sur ces questions-là
puis ensuite quand on va s'intéresser au
quotidien moi je me déplace beaucoup je
vais parler à des agents
leur préoccupations elles sont parfois
moins des grands débats idéologiques sur
l'âge de départ à la retraite que des
questions très concrètes comment la
retraite progressive ça va marcher à
partir de quel âge est-ce que mon
employeur va pouvoir me refuser
vous étiez dans dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat ou l'ambiance était un peu tendue
sur le débat sur cet article 7 est-ce
que vous comprenez la volonté de la
droite de l'accélérer et est-ce que vous
entendez la gauche qui demande plus de
temps pour ce débat
je respecte l'organisation du débat
parlementaire qui est faite par les
parlementaires je pense que c'est très
important
le gouvernement soit respectueux de ce
que décide la commission la présidente
de commission qui est examine de texte
au Sénat je vois que la droite a envie
d'avancer et de d'aller au fond du débat
et tant mieux et à parfois effectivement
je crois quelque tentations de ralentir
le débat
de faire un peu d'obstruction sur les
bancs à gauche de cette hémicycle moi je
pense que ça serait un acquis pour tout
le monde que chacun puisse se prononcer
c'est très important
qu'on puisse se prononcer la gauche a
visiblement la volonté de ne pas voter
le texte global à l'issue du temps qui
est bien imparti on a jusqu'au 12 mars à
minuit vous craignez que finalement il
n'y a pas de vote globale mais ça serait
dommage pour tout le monde et je dis ça
j'ai pas le sentiment en le disant
d'être en contradiction avec ce que
disent même les syndicats c'était ému et
ils avaient été peiné du fait qu'on
puisse même pas avoir le débat sur
l'article 7 qui est effectivement
puisque c'est celui ou notamment on
discute de l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation
c'est ça la démocratie c'est de pouvoir
en transparence devant nos concitoyens
dire ce pourquoi on est d'accord ou pas
d'accord ça doit être sale débat donc
moi je souhaite effectivement qui puisse
aller au bout je pense que c'est
possible je pense encore que c'est
possible en tout cas le gouvernement
fera tout pour elle sera à disposition
des parlementaires pour avancer débattre
et enrichir le texte un autre souci qui
se pose à vous au gouvernement c'est que
en cas de
sortie du Sénat vote ou pas votre
d'ailleurs il y aura une commission
liste paritaire un retour à l'Assemblée
nationale et bon pour le coup moi j'ai
fait les comptes et à l'heure actuelle
vous n'avez pas de majorité pour voter
ce texte à l'Assemblée nationale j'en
serai là vous êtes peut-être plus
spécialiste
et évidemment on discute avec je dirais
chaque parlementaire parce que là aussi
il faut être sincère et transparent moi
je pense que c'est très les débats qui
sont parfois difficiles parce que c'est
un texte c'est un texte d'effort qui est
pas un texte majoritairement populaire
dans l'opinion donc tout ça on le
regarde extrêmement près
je vous réponds là-dessus mais nous
notre objectif c'est de bâtir une
majorité
au Parlement non
je pense je vous réponds plus
précisément possible que c'est faisable
notre objectif depuis le début c'est de
faire adopter ce texte et de le faire
adopter 149-3 là aussi je vous réponds
la façon la plus transparente possible
mais ça majorité je vous réponds dans
l'ordre de vos questions je pense que
notre majorité sera unie pour voter le
texte que les uns et les autres puissent
se poser des questions puis se poser des
sujets d'enrichissement du texte est-ce
qu'il faut les menacer d'exclusion
a été assez flou là-dessus on a
l'impression qu'elle met une pression
quand même assez assez brutale sur sur
les réticents c'est un texte très
important
quand on vote un budget par exemple
c'est un moment qui est constitutif de
savoir si on est dans la majorité ou
dans l'opposition je pense que le texte
sur les retraites c'est un texte qui est
de cette nature là qui est extrêmement
important compris pour la suite du
quinquennat
en train de dire je je dis un important
du texte et de ma conviction qu'on
puisse convaincre y compris dans la
majorité tout simplement parce que nous
avons fait campagne avec cette réforme
là et dans une version qui chacun l'a en
tête était de travailler jusqu'à 65 ans
et parce que il y a eu un temps de
dialogue social qui a été utile parce
que il y a eu un temps de débat
parlementaire qui a été utile on a
amendé cette position pour arriver sur
64 ans et un certain nombre d'autres
enrichissements donc effectivement moi
je comprendrais pas que des députés de
la majorité qui ont fait campagne avec
cette réforme des retraites en devant
les Français et chacun savait que
c'était pas la réforme y compris pendant
la campagne qui était la plus populaire
les suffisait de regarder les études
d'opinion à ce moment-là et donc je suis
convaincu que chacun votre a ce texte
mais qui puisse y avoir du débat c'est
normal c'est absolument pas malsain et
moi j'ai déjà vécu souvent les moments
où avant les textes sont dit est-ce que
votre majorité sera unique et cetera
alors pas que la majorité mais aussi le
groupe est-ce que vous êtes la majorité
elle est toujours vous êtes vous êtes
soumis à l'incertitude autour du vote du
groupe du groupe LR il y a environ une
vingtaine de députés qui pourraient
s'abstenir ou voter contre Éric Ciotti
Olivier Marleix favorables favorables le
texte mais ils ne tiennent pas leur
groupe il y a pas une grosse incertitude
autour de ça là aussi je crois que c'est
une question de responsabilité de
cohérence et de sincérité vis-à-vis des
Français je comprendrai pas que un parti
politique une famille politique qui a
porté la question du recul de l'âge du
report de l'âge année après jusqu'au
dernières élections
ne mettent pas en cohérence leurs actes
parlementaires avec leur discours
politique je pense que simplement une
question de cohérence et de
responsabilité Julien sur la
mobilisation oui parce que pour rappeler
les chiffres on a donc eu un virgule 28
millions de manifestants ce mardi selon
la police 3 millions selon l'Inter
syndicale alors c'est une mobilisation
qui est assez inédite quand même de
depuis les dizaines d'années vous dites
que ce n'est pas la rue qui gouverne
mais peut-on gouverner contre 69% des
actifs qui à l'heure actuelle refusent
la réforme moi je
ne pose pas les différentes formes de
légitimité il y a une légitimité dans
notre pays à pouvoir manifester son
opposition boire sa colère parfois des
inquiétudes aussi faut savoir les
entendre et la légitimité des
parlementaires qui ont été élus qui sont
présentés et qui ont eu un suffrage pour
appliquer un programme politique
l'enrichir écouter je pense en avoir
fait la démonstration et l'appliquer
faut je crois respecter
des temps démocratiques dans notre pays
il y a eu un temps de dialogue social
est-ce que ce temps dialogue social a
fait bouger le texte la réponse et oui
et vous le savez très profondément le
texte qu'on a présenté au début du débat
parlementaire ça n'était pas le texte
que nous envisageions il y a eu ensuite
un temps parlementaire nous sommes dans
le temps parlementaire est-ce que le
temps parlementaire est en train de
faire bouger les lignes là aussi la
réponse est oui
c'est très clair certes ce point n'est
pas majoritaire dans l'opinion c'est
clair aussi mais est-ce qu'il faut
porter quand on s'engage dans la vie
politique que les réformes qui sont
majoritaires et populaires ce n'est pas
forcément le cas c'est aussi ça la
légitimité même encore
gouverner face à une très large majorité
des Français et moi j'ai pas le
sentiment d'être face à une majorité des
Français oui il faut être lucide sur le
fait de porter une réforme qui est j'en
suis mais absolument convaincu
nécessaire et l'intérieur vous le savez
très bien toutes les réformes des
retraites elles ont pas forcément été
toujours populaires mais ils ont jamais
été défaites par les majorités qui ont
suivi y compris quand c'était des
majorités d'alternance de gauche qui ont
même continué en réalité à allonger la
durée de cotisation il y a parfois
d'ailleurs à ce titre là des positions
qui semblent absolument
incompréhensibles aujourd'hui donc la
réalité c'est que parfois oui
on a le sentiment que ils ont absolument
pas assumé ou voté les réformes maréchal
torrent de 2014 donc moi je crois dans
la vie politique il faut de la constance
de la cohérence et un esprit de
responsabilité c'est ce dont nous
faisons preuve aujourd'hui est-ce que
Manuel Macron doit recevoir
l'intersydical c'est ce qui est demandé
je vois bien comment ce débat là au fond
comme souvent essayer de prendre des
objets vous voyez politique très
symboliques et puis que toute la vie du
pays tourne pendant 48 heures autour de
ces questions là la réalité c'est qu'il
y a un gouvernement qui est profondément
à l'écoute dans le dialogue social c'est
son rôle c'est drôle le rôle du
président de la République c'est de
donner le cap pour le pays c'est de
défendre les grands enjeux du pays
d'assurer la cohésion aussi
internationale évidemment il le fait il
est assuré
au salon de l'agriculture il y a
quelques jours il était longment
interrogé il a pu s'exprimer donc j'ai
trouvé vécu ces débat là où pendant
qu'un jour on dit est-ce que le
président parle trop et puis les 15
jours suivants est-ce qu'il ne parle pas
assez et tout ça c'est quelque chose qui
est dans le landerneau politique moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la vie des
Français c'est en l'occurrence
singulièrement la vie des agents de la
fonction publique nous sommes un
gouvernement je crois qui est vraiment
dans le dialogue social vous savez moi
je passe beaucoup de temps encore
maintenant avec les organisations
syndicales à travailler la suite les
grands enjeux le dialogue n'est pas
rompu c'est ce que vous voulez dire ce
sont des enjeux de pouvoir d'achat ce
sont des enjeux de santé au travail sur
de d'égalité salariale tout ça c'est des
enjeux mais je le dis parce que parfois
quand on regarde les plateaux de
télévision on a l'impression que tout ça
n'existe pas ça n'est pas vrai c'est des
enjeux qui comptent évidemment que le
débat sur les retraites est un débat
très bien que ça va un petit peu la
lumière médiatique mais justement on
parle on parle de la fonction publique
et on voulait parler des retraites
progrès progressives le Sénat a proposé
un d'ouvrir le droit à la retraite
progressive des des 60 ans au lieu de 62
ans dans la formation publique c'est
quelque chose auquel vous êtes favorable
on va on va discuter cette mesure là moi
je suis favorable est-ce qu'on puisse
d'abord introduire la retraite
progressive dans la fonction publique ça
n'existait pas c'est une avancée majeure
ça permet pour ceux qui nous écoutent à
un agent en fin de carrière 60 62 ans de
pouvoir se mettre à temps partiel en
conservant sa rémunération je pense que
c'est très important et je vois que
cette mesure là intéresse et les agents
et les syndicats de la fonction publique
je pense au syndicat ou aux agents de
l'éducation nationale c'est les
professeurs il y a beaucoup de gens qui
se disent parce que je pourrais avoir
cette possibilité d'aménager mon temps
de travail donc moi ma première
préoccupation c'est que ça existe là
aussi pour de vrai c'est pour ça que je
travaille c'est important parce que les
certains syndicats je pense à la effet
Suisse interroger en disant est-ce qu'on
va pas nous sans arrêt nous nous opposer
le fait qu'il y a une nécessité de
service et donc le professeur en
question il a pas le droit de partir et
c'est précisément pour ça pardon je
prends un tout petit peu de temps pour
le gars parce qu'il me semble que ça
c'est le vrai débat moi j'ai réuni
secrétaire généraux des ministères les
DRH des ministères vous voyez c'est
quelque chose parfois qu'on faisait pas
suffisamment en leur passant à une
consigne très claire c'est comment
est-ce que ce texte là ça devient pas
simplement un droit de papier ça devient
une réalité et que on réfléchit et on
aménage les carrières pour que ça soit
possible donc là dessus moi je vais être
le plus clair possible je veux que la
retraite progressive elle s'applique
pleinement et que ça soit un droit pour
les agents c'est d'ailleurs les
améliorations de la retraite progressive
qui sont portées par ce texte-là y
compris pour le privé c'est l'employeur
qui va devoir justifier au fond si
jamais il n'est pas d'accord il y a une
forme de la charge de la preuve si
l'employeur décide de ne pas accorder la
retraite progressive ensuite 60 62 ans
on va en discuter je vois que les
sénateurs ont préparé une version qui
est évolutive serait 80% entre 60 et 72
ans un peu plus après pourquoi pas c'est
un restaurant à une condition c'est
qu'il faut qu'on puisse savoir financer
l'ensemble oui j'allais dire vous avez
une idée du coup de cette de cette
mesure vous l'avez vous l'avez mesuré je
crois que c'est entre 100 et 150
millions d'euros supplémentaires vous
voyez que c'est pas rien si jamais on
ouvre un peu plus tôt cette possibilité
de retrait de progressive donc moi je
suis favorable sur le principe à la
seule condition qu'on puisse conserver
l'équilibre du texte donc c'est pour ça
c'est différent
c'est qu'on peut se garder le cap celui
de l'équilibre financier parce que c'est
la condition pas pour se faire plaisir
pour équilibrer les comptes mais pour
conserver et préserver
l'équilibre financier actuellement de
cette réforme de retraite quand même
très très fragile c'est pour ça là aussi
j'essaie de vous répondre de façon la
plus transparente possible toutes ces
questions là il faut les regarder à
l'aune de l'équilibre global financier
c'est peut-être des discussions qu'on
aura dans le cadre de la commission
mixte paritaire pour reprendre les
différents enrichissements du texte et
puis avoir des choix politiques mais
avec un grand P aussi de ce qu'on décide
collectivement pour notre système il y
avait un choix politique qui devrait
être d'ailleurs être discuté aujourd'hui
dans l'hémicycle de Bruno Retailleau
c'était de d'accélérer la suppression
des régimes spéciaux pour que ça
commence progressivement dès 2025 et que
tout le monde soit 64 ans en 2040
pourquoi le refuser c'est un manque de
courage politique de la part du
gouvernement non d'abord je pense que là
aussi c'est la conscience et de la
clarté
ça repose sur un double engagement nous
avons dit que nous conserverons pour les
salariés pour les agents en poste
aujourd'hui les régimes spéciaux parce
que c'est le pacte social c'est un
double engagement parce que le Président
de la République l'a dit pendant la
campagne et parce que le gouvernement là
réaffirmé donc je pense qu'il faut
donner de la stabilité à notre débat de
la clarté pour celles et ceux qui
s'interrogent qui se sont inscrits dans
une carrière avec pacte social à un
moment donné et qui ont le droit d'avoir
ce pacte social respecté je crois que
nous devons prendre cette mesure là tel
que nous l'avons fait c'est à dire avec
une clause du grand-père elle concernera
les nouveaux salariés les nouveaux
agents ce qu'on a fait pour la SNCF je
fais remarquer que ça bouge quand même
parce que parfois j'entends dire alors
ça veut dire que rien ne se passe avant
40 ans rien n'est plus faux la réalité
c'est que ça commence à bouger les
lignes dès les nouvelles embauches dès
les nouveaux départs à la retraite avec
le renouvellement
toujours quasiment 80 ans oui parfois
pardon je vois avec un peu de sourire le
fait que on vienne nous dire aujourd'hui
ce que nous n'avons pas faire avant vous
vous le faites mais là il faudra le
faire plus rapidement là aussi je pense
qu'il faut un petit peu de conscience
cette cohérence un autre dossier qui
vous intéresse en tant que ministre de
la Fonction publique c'est l'index
égalité professionnelle que vous avez
présenté qui va être étendu à la
fonction publique pour assurer une
égalité femme homme supplémentaire alors
quatre ans après son entrée en vigueur
dans le privé cela dit selon une étude
de l'Institut des politiques publiques
qui a été faite réalisée avec la CFDT
l'index égalité professionnelle n'a eu
qu'un effet limité dans le privé alors
j'allais dire est-ce que on peut pas
avoir le la même crainte pour sa
réalisation dans le public deux choses
d'abord un index c'est fait pour pointer
donc ça ça permet d'abord de partir d'un
constat partagé lucide et de faire
ensuite bouger les lignes avec des
possibilités de sanctions financières
vous voyez le débat sur l'index seniors
tels que les choses ont été pensées si
les lignes ne bougent pas
des sanctions financières
mais je pars du privé où on a mis en
place l'index et puis ensuite on a donné
3 ans aux entreprises pour bouger les
lignes c'est un petit peu normal que
quatre ans après les lignes commencent à
bouger sur ces sujets là donc moi je
souhaite que on fasse la même chose pour
les fonctions publiques avec
effectivement des possibilités de
sanctions financières pour les
administrations passages faire marrer
que ça existe déjà il y a un dispositif
aujourd'hui de nomination équilibrée tu
es issu de la loi sauvadée ou si les
administrations tiennent pas un certain
nombre d'objectifs ça permet de financer
d'ailleurs de financer des fonds en
faveur de l'application de mesure
d'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
donc le dispositif existe déjà et puis
ensuite ma deuxième remarque c'est que
l'index ça doit pas évidemment être la
seule mesure pour faire l'égalité
salariale c'est un dispositif un outil
complémentaire pour ensuite mettre en
place des plans depuis trois ans il y a
des plans d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes qui s'appliquent j'aurais
vous voyez avec les syndicats l'occasion
de renégocier ces plans là pour les
années à venir ça fait partie de nos
chantiers 2023 on va continuer à avancer
sur les nominations dans les postes à
plus forte responsabilités il y avait un
objectif de 40 % de femmes dans les
prémonominations depuis 2020 on a
dépassé cet objectif j'ai annoncé et je
réunirai tout à l'heure des syndicats
des collectifs d'agents pour annoncer
qu'on va rendre encore plus ambitieux
celui de domination 45% de nomination
équilibrée dans les postes à plus haute
responsabilités dans les administrations
50% pour tous les emplois à décision du
gouvernement et puis qu'on va regarder
aussi pas simplement le flux de
nomination mais le stock d'emploi que
les 40% d'ici la fin du quinquennat ont
pu savoir atteint les 40% c'est à dire
et c'est ça la révolution aussi
culturelle de se doter d'une obligation
non pas simplement de nomination mais de
résultat à la fin du match donc vous
voyez qu'on avance surtout il y aura le
5 avril examiné dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat une proposition de loi justement
pour renforcer l'accès des femmes aux
responsabilités dans la fonction
publique est-ce que vous soutiendrez ce
texte oui pour la très bonne raison que
je travaille depuis des mois avec les
délégations du droit des femmes au Sénat
à l'Assemblée je l'ai réuni dans
quelques jours le 17 mars pour avoir un
moment de travail et préparer ensemble
ce texte donc moi ce texte là je le vois
comme l'opportunité législative de
pouvoir donner une traduction réelle
concrète aux engagements que je prends
aujourd'hui à la fois sur l'index à la
fois sur le dispositif de nomination
équilibrée concerner qu'on est vraiment
nominés à tout le monde vous avez bien
compris que l'index est une photographie
d'ensemble et des dispositifs de
correction voire de sanctions qu'on
renforce encore l'ambition du dispositif
de nomination équilibré et que tout ça
je souhaite en faire un sujet
trans partisans trans chambre si je puis
dire et que tous ensemble on est là une
belle avancée collective pour l'égalité
salariale j'ajoute pardon un mot parce
que je pense que il faut se battre pour
l'égalité économique mais il faut
davantage aussi travailler sur les
conditions de travail je pense que si on
améliore pas très concrètement
l'environnement de travail alors parfois
on a quelques vœux pieux dans des
objectifs chiffrés c'est pour ça que les
sujets par exemple de santé au travail
justement de santé des femmes sont des
sujets qui sont très importants j'allais
vous interroger là-dessus puisque parmi
les autres mesures vous avez annoncé la
fin du délai de carence pour les arrêts
maladie liés aux fausses couches est-ce
que vous réfléchissez à d'autres mesures
pour pour la santé notamment des des
femmes pour ces femmes victimes
d'endométriose ou d'autres maladies oui
bien sûr je l'ai dit j'en parlerai
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure ça fait partie
du plan
sur lequel je souhaite que dans les
prochains mois on puisse avancer avancer
très fort sur la prévention on fait pas
cette prévention c'est connu dans notre
pays on fait surtout pas assez de
prévention au travail sur à la fois des
maladies chroniques sur des sujets qui
sont très importants comme les cancers
les cancers féminins les interviennent
de plus en plus tôt donc je travaille là
aussi sur tous les angles c'est-à-dire à
la fois des dispositifs de prévoyance je
suis en train de mener négociation très
importante pour introduire un dispositif
de prévoyance dans la fonction publique
c'est-à-dire de meilleur couverture des
risques qui touchent les agents sur les
décès sur l'invalidité sur les arrêts
longues maladies ce serait plus une
mutuelle complémentaire à la discrétion
de chaque agent de se couvrir ou pas
mais ça serait une grande avancée
sociale c'est-à-dire que l'employeur
public se mettrait au bon niveau pour
mieux couvrir pour tous ces agents ces
risques et ces risques lourds et parfois
de plus en plus important mais là aussi
je pense qu'il faut avancer sur ces
sujets là nouveau parfois en tant
qu'employeur public et puis faire en
sorte que des décisions qu'on prend elle
s'appliquent pour de bons vous avez
mentionné la suppression du jour de
carence pour les femmes qui subissent
des fausses couches et très important
plus de 150 000 femmes chaque année qui
subissent une fausse couche la situation
aujourd'hui les absolument inacceptable
c'est-à-dire que légitimement votre
médecin vous prescrire un arrêt de
travail et en plus d'avoir des
conséquences parfois physiques parfois
psychologiques vous avez une conséquence
financière parce que vous avez un jour
de carence bon on va supprimer ça mais
je veux que ça s'applique pour de bon
c'est à dire en garantissant aussi la
confidentialité du dispositif et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on est en train de
travailler dans le détail avec
l'Assurance Maladie pour que on puisse
passer par un tiers et garantir
vis-à-vis du DRH tout simplement une
confidentialité complète c'est la
condition pour que ce type d'avancée ce
sont des avancées elles puissent non pas
simplement aider avancées formelles de
papier mais des avancées réelles dans la
vie des agents merci Stanislas Guérini
merci beaucoup d'avoir été invité la Une
de La Voix du Nord les projets routiers
ont-ils encore un avenir
merci beaucoup Stanislas Guérini